Hello, I'm Terry Fisher.
This is the last in a series of 12
lectures on the subject of copyright.
I'll be discussing today the
remedies that the law makes
available for copyright infringement.
As usual, I will concentrate on
copyright law in the United States,
but will also identify some ways
in which the law in other countries
differs from that in the United States,
and some ways in which all countries
are now constrained by
multilateral copyright treaties.
Also as usual, the lecture
will be accompanied
by various audiovisual materials, which
include maps of copyright doctrine
and copyright theory.
The current versions of which may
be downloaded from my home page.
The address of which is tfisher.org.
There are three types of remedy
for copyright infringement--
equitable, legal, and criminal.
The first two types are available to the
prevailing plaintiffs in civil suits.
In other words, a copyright
owner who, in a civil lawsuit,
successfully demonstrates that a
defendant has engaged in copyright
infringement may attain either or
both equitable or legal remedies.
In addition, a person who engages in
some types of copyright infringement
may be prosecuted by the
government and, if convicted,
subjected to criminal sanctions.
The three segments of this lecture will
examine these three types of remedy
in sequence.
The primary form of equitable
relief consists of injunctions.
Injunctions are orders by courts
directing someone to do something
or, more commonly, to
stop doing something.
In copyright suits, by far the
most common type of injunction
is an instruction to the defendant
to cease engaging in the behavior
that a court has deemed
to be infringing.
Statutory authority for the
issuance of such injunctions
is contained in section
502 of the copyright
statute, which is set
forth on your screen.
As you can see, section 502 provides
that "any court having jurisdiction
of a civil action
arising under this title
may grant temporary and final
injunctions on such terms
as it may deem reasonable to prevent or
restrain infringement of a copyright."
Note the reference to "temporary
and final injunctions."
Those adjectives allude
to the fact that there
are, in the American
legal system, two species
of injections-- permanent injunctions
and so-called preliminary injunctions.
Permanent injunctions,
as their name suggests,
are typically issued at the conclusion
of a copyright infringement suit.
Preliminary injunctions,
as their name suggests,
are issued by a court before
the conclusion of the suit--
often long before the
conclusion of the suit--
when it becomes apparent that the
defendant will likely in the end lose,
and that allowing the defendant's
behavior to continue in the meantime
would cause the
plaintiff serious injury.
The principals governing when
it's appropriate for courts
to issue either of these
two types of injunction
are set forth on your screen.
These principles were not developed in
the context of copyright infringement
lawsuits.
Rather, they were
developed by the courts--
specifically by the federal courts--
to govern equitable relief in general.
As you can see, the traditional
rule was that a plaintiff, in order
to obtain a permanent
injunction, must show--
first, that she has suffered
an irreparable injury;
second, that the monetary damages
would be inadequate to compensate her
for that injury; third, that she
would suffer more serious hardship
if an injunction were denied than would
the defendant if an injunction were
granted; and finally, that
the public interest would not
be disserved by the
issuance of an injunction.
The traditional rules governing
preliminary injunctions
were slightly different.
To obtain one of these,
a plaintiff was obliged
to show-- first, that
she is likely to suffer
an irreparable injury if the
defendant's conduct continues;
second, that monetary damages would
be inadequate to compensate her
for that injury; third, that
the balance of hardships,
again, tilts in her favor; fourth,
that the public interest would not
be disturbed; and last but
not least, that she is likely,
at the conclusion of the lawsuit,
to succeed in demonstrating
the illegality of the
defendant's behavior.
This last factor has the effect of
making judicial decisions concerning
the availability of
preliminary injunctive relief
into provisional assessments of the
merits of the plaintiff's claims.
Although technically only provisional,
in practice such judgments
often terminate controversies.
As I say, these principles
have long governed
the availability of
injunctive relief in general.
By contrast, in copyright
lawsuits, until quite recently,
different standards obtained.
Specifically, courts
in copyright suits were
more likely to grant either
preliminary or permanent injunctions
than in most other
kinds of controversies.
Courts typically took the
position that a demonstration
by the plaintiff that she is likely to
succeed on the merits of a copyright
infringement suit gives rise to
a presumption of irreparable harm
sufficient to warrant issuance of a
preliminary or permanent injunction.
As a result, granting injunctions to
prevailing plaintiffs was routine.
To be sure, it was not automatic.
On occasions, courts would deny
injunctions in special circumstances.
The three most famous
instances in which courts
suggested that injunctions
should not invariably be granted
are listed on your screen.
You may recall that in the
case of Stewart versus Abend,
the author of a short story granted a
license to make a motion picture based
on that story-- a license
that eventually ended up
in the hands of James Stewart
and Alfred Hitchcock--
and resulted, in their hands, in the
creation of the movie Rear Window.
Unfortunately, both for the
author and for the movie makers,
the author of the short story died
before the end of his first 28 year
copyright term.
And thus, he was unable
to renew the copyright.
Instead, his executor
renewed the copyright,
and then assigned it to a third
party who promptly brought suit
against Hitchcock and
his company, seeking
to enjoin future
performances of Rear Window
unless and until the defendants
obtained a new license.
You'll recall, I hope, that the
Supreme Court eventually sided
with the plaintiff-- the
assignee of the renewal term.
However, the Court of
Appeals for the Ninth Circuit
took the position that
the plaintiff was not
necessarily entitled to an injunction.
Instead, in view of
the good faith reliance
by the filmmakers on
the original license,
a reasonable monetary award would be
more appropriate than an injunction.
Another special circumstance was
identified by the United States Supreme
Court in the Campbell case, which
I discussed in lecture number nine.
You'll recall, I hope, that
the Supreme Court in that case
took the position that the defendant
who, without permission, prepares
a parody of a copyrighted work is likely
to prevail under the fair use doctrine.
However, Justice Souter,
writing for the court,
suggested that parodist
would not always succeed.
After taking into account all
four of the fair use factors,
a court might conclude that a particular
parody should not be deemed a fair use.
In such circumstances, however,
Souter suggested, in dictum,
that the defendant might
be permitted to continue
to distribute his or
her parody, provided
he or she paid the plaintiff
an appropriate damage award.
Finally, in the Tasini case, the Supreme
Court suggested, again in dictum,
that injunctive relief could be
denied when it's issuance would
frustrate "the goals of copyright law."
The upshot, in short, is
that courts occasionally
rejected plaintiffs'
requests for injunctions.
In the overwhelming majority of
cases, however, prevailing plaintiffs
were deemed to be entitled
to injunctive relief.
In 2006, the Supreme
Court decided a case
that changed this
landscape fundamentally.
Until that date, most federal courts
had dealt with patent infringement suits
in much the same way they dealt
with copyright infringement suits--
granting injunctive relief nearly
automatically to prevailing plaintiffs.
The Supreme Court, in eBay, declared
that that practice could not
be justified on the basis of the
language of the patent statute.
Henceforth, the court ruled
that traditional rules, which
I summarized a minute
ago, should be employed
to determine whether injunctive relief
was appropriate in patent cases.
In particular, a plaintiff would have
to establish, among other things,
that the balance of
hardships tilted in her favor
and that the issuance of
an injunction would not
undermine the public interest.
The opinion of the Supreme
Court in the eBay case
did not provide much guidance
concerning what adherence to those rules
would produce.
However, two concurring
opinions in the case did so.
Chief Justice Roberts, in an opinion
joined by justices Scalia and Ginsburg,
suggested that in the
future federal courts,
when applying the traditional
rules governing equitable
relief to patent
disputes, should continue
to be somewhat more favorably disposed
to the issuance of injunctions
than in non-patent cases in light of
the traditional practice of granting
such injunctions nearly automatically.
By contrast, Justice Kennedy, in an
opinion joined by justices Stevens,
Souter and Breyer, identified
three circumstances
in which, in their judgment, court
should be especially reluctant to issue
injunctions-- when the plaintiff is
a so-called non-practicing entity,
sometimes referred to as a patent
troll; when the patent at issue
covers one component
of a complex product,
and thus issuance of an
injunction would give
the patentee disproportionate
bargaining power
when negotiating for a subsequent
license; and when the patent at issue
pertains to a method of doing
business, a context in which patent
protection, they believed,
is especially problematic.
Although, as you can see,
Justice Kennedy was only
speaking for four
justices, his opinion has
proven to be influential in patent law.
In the eBay decision, the
Supreme Court intimated
that the issuance of
injunctions in copyright cases
should be governed by
the same principles
that henceforth would govern the
issuance injunctions in patent cases.
As one might expect,
given that clear signal,
most district courts in copyright cases
subsequently adopted the eBay approach.
But a few continued to adhere to
the traditional practice, which,
as we've seen, strongly
favored plaintiffs.
In 2010 and 2011, the influential Courts
of Appeals in the Second and Ninth
Circuits, removed any
remaining doubt concerning
the applicability of eBay to copyright.
In the Salinger and Perfect
10 cases, those courts
ruled decisively that permanent
and preliminary injunctions
could be granted in copyright
cases only upon satisfaction
of the traditional multi-factor tests.
So that's where things stand today.
The net result is that it is
significantly harder nowadays
to obtain an injunction
than it was seven years ago.
This shift likely seems to you
quite technical, and it is.
But its impact is fundamental.
In the growing percentage of cases in
which prevailing copyright plaintiffs
are denied injunctive relief
and are granted only damages,
the courts are, in effect, creating
compulsory licensing regimes
forcing, in other words,
copyright owners to accept
a governmentally determined license
fee in return for allowing defendants
to continue to engage in conduct
forbidden by copyright law.
Plaintiffs who would prefer to charge
more, or to deny permission altogether,
have no choice but to accept the
amount of money selected by the court
and to tolerate the continuation
of the defendant's behavior.
Twice, earlier in this
lecture series, we
have discussed the merits and demerits
of compulsory licensing systems.
First, from the perspective
of welfare theory,
and then in the context of
public performance rights.
At the time, we were primarily
concerned with compulsory licensing
systems that had been
created by statute.
As we saw, such statutory
regimes now govern several uses
of copyrighted works-- for example,
covers of copyrighted songs,
retransmissions of signals
by cable television
or satellite systems, juke
boxes, derivative works based
upon the restored foreign
copyrights, and so forth.
But judicially created
compulsory licenses
implicate many of the
same concerns that arise
in connection with statutory
compulsory licenses.
I hope that you can see
how the eBay decision has
had the effect of sharply increasing
the set of such judicial compulsory
licenses.
Whether that impact will
be socially and culturally
beneficial remains to be seen
This concludes our discussion
of equitable relief.
After the break, I will examine
the even more complex set
of rules that determine the magnitude of
the monetary awards to which prevailing
plaintiffs in civil suits are entitled.